good afternoon -- the rules
committee for Monday July first
nineteen is hereby call to
order please yet buys an audio
and video recording of today's
proceedings be made as all spend
televised on them secretary
please call the roll Cooley
Cunningham Carillo here flora
Grayson Kamlager-Dove here
Maienschein Mathis quirk
Silva almost here Rivas
Wicks the California -- we
have a quorum and we have a
consent agenda -- present noted
includes river for over SB three
fifteen Hertzberg the river tax
committee it was on the list of
servers I searchlight authors
to sort of fell off but is
back on again -- that will be
referred to run tax committee --
is our motion the consent agenda
so excited over Mr Grayson
senator Mister problems --
and center please call the roll
Cooley hi Cooley aye Cunningham
Cunningham I. Carillo Carillo
aye flora Lara I recent
Grayson aye Kamlager-Dove time
Kamlager-Dove I Maienschein
Maienschein aye Mathis
on consent all right at the site
so by Romans Ramos I
Rivas Rivas aye and worse
that motion is passed and --
rules minister and taking her